perfect yeah i also got a
confirmation hello everybody one more
time and i'm raghavendran i'm a research
consultant and mentor with pine biot
economics logic i'm trained in
bioinformatics and i hold a phd in
computational biology from max plunk
institute of germany
my broad research interests include our
my broad resurgences are in the
application of data science methods to
understand cancer biology my role in
find biotech includes developing
curricula for the platform and also
mentoring students in the research
fellowship program and also in the
programs that you'll go to sign up
please allow me to talk about few
example projects that we have prepared
in the platform learn or mix logic
platform that will help you appreciate
how bioinformatics analysis can be
leveraged to understand the biology of
pathogens and to study infectious
diseases
so first we will focus on a project that
studies the current pandemic covid19 so
in this project we explored the pathogen
source coronavirus itself and
as well as two diseases that that are
caused by it
so this project will help you explore
the origin of the pandemic and how
different diseases are caused by this
pathogen and how they are related to
existing uh strains from human
coronavirus and also
to other strains from animals
sources also so we will do this by using
publicly available data from
repositories like ncbi writers and
geo data etc
so we will learn in this project we will
learn to perform or how to perform
multiple sequence alignment followed by
phallogenetic analysis these analysis
will help us compare the existing
strains of coronavirus to understand the
zoonotic origins of the disease
so we will also learn in detail how to
interpret results from
analysis like multiple sequence
alignment to understand mutational
changes in the genome of source co2
compared to different strains as i have
already told strains from humans and
also strains from different animals
next we will also see uh what are the
important protein components of the
virus through which they enter into the
human cell and we will we will also
learn how to visualize the identified
mutations on the spike protein for
example and from such analysis and such
visualization we can understand and we
can study which mutation might affect
the functional properties of this spike
protein and alter its ability to bind to
the receptor in the host cell so
furthermore we will also
learn how we can look for
transcriptomics data from uh from
patients that are infected with cyscop2
using
public repositories like g gene
expression omnibus database and etcetera
here we will explore uh such data this
data in particular to find out important
transcriptional signatures that are
associated with drug treatments like
rook root solution
rucks in
short we will also learn some important
bioinformatics methods that are
available for identifying gene
expression signature
uh for treatments like rooks or
rexolotinib we will perform differential
gene expression analysis between rust
treated and untreated samples and we
will also employ unsupervised machine
learning methods like principal
component analysis and clustering to
understand the potential of these
signatures
in categorizing drug-treated and
untreated samples
so
yeah
during the course of this project you
will learn how to do and the logic
behind such analysis and how to
interpret these analysis in the context
of the
data or in the context of the biological
project or question
so next project we will
get introduced to is on the outbreak of
enterovirus d68 or evd68 in short this
is a wireless that causes a severe
neurogenic disease called acute flaccid
mellitus afm in short mainly in children
so it is a
in comparison it is a polio like illness
defined by the acute onset on
spine or on the paralysis of the spine
so in this project we will understand
the evolutionary relationship between
the strains of different outbreaks of
this virus so
to go into the history this virus first
emerged around 1960s and in the last
decade itself the outbreak of ebd 68 has
been reported across different parts of
the globe even in developed countries
like united states
europe and roughly once in two years or
once in three years or so on
so their pathogenicity also varies among
these outbreaks and among different
populations of these uh virus
so similar to the sas project here also
we will use various phylogenetic
pre-reconstruction techniques and
algorithms to find out whether the ebd68
strains from different outbreaks or
different time points like 2014 16 18
are
from the same virus or from the same
strain or from the different strain or
related virus using next-gen sequencing
data of the patients so we will also see
that phylogenetic analysis reflects the
variations in the strain that causes
these outbreaks in different years or in
different time points furthermore
multiple sequence alignment will reveal
a number of variations in the sequences
of different viral strains a careful
analysis and how to perform this
calculator analysis
will help us identify critical mutations
that can cause significant changes in
the amino acid level among these
different strains these mutations can be
related to the virulent properties of
the pathogen and will help us
characterize the viruses like evd68 or
star scope 2 which is currently
a very dangerous pandemic going on based
on their pathogenesis
hope that was informative and
that was very interesting and i look
forward to meet many of you in the
bioinformatics for infection